how did you
come to this i mean did you go through a
whole audition process for this film how
do you
how do you do all this and not fall in
love with the character before you know
you get to play her
good question
um
yeah i
i try my hardest not to fall in love
with characters before i get to play
them um but this one i couldn't help
but fall in love and it was actually a
very emotional journey for me
um i read the script and fell in love i
taped
and
heard that i
was going to meet with dj the director i
met with dj
and
i
then i believe the process was a
like a month long this was like i think
what two years ago now um
but
i got it but then there was a scheduling
conflict
so
i ended up having to let the role go and
i was devastated yeah
um yeah cause dates for another project
conflicted and so
i actually heard
months later that because i kept asking
about it and i was like i just i really
hope that they push like i hope that the
dates push
and i heard that they did
so i actually took it upon myself to
write dj a
um
basically an essay
telling him all about like how much i
love the role and how much i just
i hope that i like i
would have the honor to play angel and
um
yeah we ended up chatting again and then
since the dates pushed i was able to do
it so it was a very long emotional
journey because i i mean
was in love with with this the story and
angel story so
yeah had you known or heard anything
about the book or was it just the script
that made you fall in love with her
so it was originally the script i um
i had
friends and family who had read the book
um
i was not familiar with it so i
yeah i read the script and i loved it
and um
yeah my mom actually was like oh my gosh
i read that book i loved it
so after reading the script i i did i
read the book and i mean
i can see why
how daunting is it then to know that you
actually have like this group of fans
that is already there who already wants
to see the movie and you have that
expectation
how do you tune that out
yeah i mean i i feel i have a huge
responsibility to this role and to the
to the fans of the book and you know to
to angel
i
i try my best not to let it um
you know
be in my mind 24 7 when i'm filming
because it is a it is very it's a
daunting it's a daunting task and it's a
um
yeah it is it is some pressure but you
know i
i really do want to do angel justice for
the fans and for the people who who
really you know adore this book and who
have
loved it for for years so
um yeah i think i think it's just a
matter of
you know doing your proper research and
preparation and then
um
really leaving it at the door and when
you're on set just
letting your creative
energy and artistic
uh energy flow so
this film doesn't work if the chemistry
between angel and michael isn't there
and if the audience doesn't care about
them so at what point in the process did
you guys
meet and how did you i mean did it did
you have conversations about that
relationship
we met in south africa
so
it which is so funny i mean
looking back like oh my gosh
um
it could have gone so wrong but yeah
luckily you know we met and we
immediately we just hit it off and i
mean tom is incredible um
he's a great great person great friends
so
yeah i i adore him um
but yeah we did we did kem reads um we
actually did do chemistry reads but he
was in the uk at the time and um i
flew into south africa before
i think we even had our michael
um
so
dj called me into his office and was
like we have our michael this is him
showed me his tape and i was like okay
great he's like he arrives next week i
was like awesome
so yeah we met in south africa
did it find like once you guys finally
got to do a scene together did that
really sort of help you feel like it was
all in place
yeah it really did um
i mean
just from meeting tom i
you just kind of know so i was like okay
this is gonna be this is gonna be great
i feel like we're in a really
we both felt very comfortable with each
other um but we did do some rehearsals
at i believe
like one of our houses dj met with us
and we just kind of went through scenes
and stuff and
um
yeah immediately we were just
you know very excited for
what was to come
he's really one of the only characters
that actually
treats angel well she doesn't have you
know the the best people in her life
right so what was it like to really
figure out all those relationships and
those dynamics and work with those
different actors you have so many
people that you're doing scenes with who
are not treating her well
yeah um
it was
you know it was
i got very lucky and i
you know it was just a very safe
environment and a wonderful um
place to be able to do those types of
scenes
so and i mean and by that i mean the
the cast they were all just so lovely
and respectful and kind and professional
so
um yeah we definitely lucked out there
so i think that made it
you know insanely
um
i wouldn't say easy but uh
much yeah much easier than it you know
would have been otherwise so
even though there really is no shortage
of horrible men in this story for me
someone like duchess is worse as another
female who's
selling these young women
so how do you feel about that character
or what she represents to angel
yeah um
i think that
duchess
is
almost a
motherly figure to to angel because you
know she her mother
her mother passed yeah
and she has this
negative outlook on life now and
now this is the only other woman that's
been in authority to her
um
and i think it just
kind of
further
proves angel's theory that everything is
horrible and
nothing can go right so
um
i also think that
seeing
angel watching
duchess
listen to mcgowan as well is
a painful thing too i don't think she's
ever seen really any women in her life
stand up to
two men and
stand up to
you know their abusers and duchess is
just
his right-hand
man or woman so
um it's a
yeah it's a it's definitely a very
complicated relationship there
i first became aware of you with
chilling adventures of sabrina
and
you've gone on to lead this film you're
also leading date the winx saga which is
also
did really well
and is coming back for a second season
so what uh what can you say to tease the
second season of that show especially
for fans who have been waiting and and
we'll be still waiting a little bit
longer to get to see it
yeah it will be a little bit i think um
yeah i mean
i don't know how much i can say i'm
so bad with
giving spoilers so i'm like i have to
like be careful um
i would say i mean there's
there's more they're more
threats to the universe there are more
um we're introducing new characters
um
more love stories
um
more magic more fighting
and yeah just
bigger threats and more
questions being answered
i know it's very vague and people are
gonna get
well what your what was your reaction to
getting to read the scripts getting to
see how the world would get expanded
how did you feel about especially after
playing her for a season how did you
feel about where she'd be going next
um
yeah i mean i was excited i i i'm a fan
like i
you know of of the series so
getting the the scripts
it was just it was like christmas
morning it was exciting um we don't get
the scripts all in one so we actually
will get like a script film the episode
and then we don't know what's coming
next either so which is
exciting and kind of nerve-wracking
so it's kind of yeah it's it's it's
it was awesome
what do you think fans would be most
surprised to learn about the making of
that show
that the majority of it is
cgi
well i'm sure they know that
i don't actually have fire powers um
uh
the
some of the things
that go into the cgi like
me like when i have my firepowers i have
to like
well season one it was like a literally
like a rod like a metal rod on my
forearm and then just like a light
attached and i would have to like move
like this
just to like hope
and they like they cgi'd it out but
that's how i would do my firepowers
because the light would hit my face
um
but it's stuff like that it would be
you know you'd be talking to a metal
ball and pretending it's a monster so
it's not as
maybe glamorous as people may think it's
very
sometimes you sit back and you're like
wow this is this is my job i'm an adult
and i'm talking to a metal ball
was the character like angel difficult
to let go of on the last day was she
someone that you after playing her had
become attached to in that sense
i think
i hope i i did a decent job of
protecting myself
um when it came to
playing angel
um
and you can only do so much because at
the end of the day you know it is
it is your body getting thrown around or
whatever
stunt doubles and stuff like that but um
you are the one
doing the scenes and it could be another
yeah it's a character but i mean i'd be
lying if i said it didn't
take a bit of a toll on
on me but i feel like
you know i had a lot of people around me
that were very supportive and very kind
and
and
created a really safe environment so
that was
insanely helpful and
you know if there was something
healing but
um yeah i try i definitely try to kind
of separate myself from the character
especially in that kind of um
situation because or circumstance
because it can
um
i mean it's really tough material so
yeah
what was the last scene that you shot
and what was that last day like
um
the last day
uh and the last scene you're asking what
senior yeah the last scene was the last
the last day was the last scene of the
movie and that was the last scene that
we did
so
we were
chasing light which means the sun was
going down and we had a certain amount
of time to get this scene done i was
insanely sick so
like my i yeah i don't know i think i
had food poisoning or something so i
would like it yeah it was
it was a interesting
interesting uh last day but we were we
were all pushing through and everyone
you know everyone was very
very supportive and i was like
dead set on getting this done so i was
you know
pushing through some uh yeah food
poisoning and all that it was a very uh
interesting last day um but
we got it done and it was
looking back you know it was uh
it's one of those moments that you
remember for like the rest of your life
it's like remember how hectic and like
scared we were that we weren't gonna get
this done and you know
just the feeling of of accomplishment is
is uh especially the last scene of the
movie on the last day
it was a yeah it's a really
odd but good memory
well no one no one will know what
happened during the filming so
you can't tell so
thank you so much i probably shouldn't
have said that like
now you're gonna watch the last scene
and think of it differently like
well you do beautiful work in this and i
appreciate you talking about it thank
you so much
thank you so much
you